nicole bricq la ministre du commerce
extérieur est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir madame briques et merci d'être
avec nous au moment où la france peine à
redresser ses exportations vous pourrez
vous le confirmer dans un instant et
père de son crédit par ailleurs auprès
d'une nouvelle agence de notation
moody's cette fois après standard and
poor c'était en février dernier on s'en
souvient des polémiques de l'époque
l'urgence est donc là dans les résultats
espérés des mesures pour la
compétitivité et des réformes françois
hollande répète devant les maires de
france que le cap est fixé et qu'il doit
être suivi jean luc prévost de l' agence
france-presse
notre partenaire nous rejoindra dans un
instant suivi de perrine tarneaud et qui
reviendra notamment sur votre rentrée
mouvementée au gouvernement et les
téléspectateurs peuvent intervenir et
vous interpeller au cours de cette
émission par le biais de l'application
tivi tchèque de notre partenaire
également orange
le nouveau président de l'ump que vous
connaissez bien nicole bricq un vol
avait battu aux élections législatives à
mot c'était en 1997 jean françois copé
donc attaqué la politique du
gouvernement il parle même de son
discrédit et ce qu'il dit la même chose
en plus violent que agence moody's jean
françois copé je ne reconnais bien là il
ferait mieux de s'occuper de son parti
quand même parce qu' un parti aussi est
rare chic aussi verticale qui fait 50 50
alors qu'il a le culte du chef ça doit
pas être facile à diriger
oui mais vous reconnaissez la le cogneur
que vous avez affronté en seine et marne
écoutez moi je l'avais croisé il n'y a
pas très longtemps à vous et il me dit
où les journalistes
est-ce que je vais être battu je lui dis
c'est bon signe et je vous connais vous
êtes très bien organisée bon je me suis
pas trompé cela étant ce qui arrive à
l'ump on peut réjouir personne parce que
au travers de ce discrédit quelque part
il ya le mot de discuter oui ça ça
attire l'attention sur quelques fois la
fragilité des partis politiques qui sont
indispensables à la vie démocratique et
nous avons besoin d'une opposition forte
qu'ils fassent des propositions qui se
projette un peu si l'ump va passer son
temps à se quereller pour telle ou telle
fédération pour tel ou tel sujet qui va
les diviser ça ne profitera le cas ceux
qui sont les ennemis de la démocratie
des jeux sur wii pas deux options après
ce qu'il s'est passé
certains même au sein de l'ump on
parlait de farce à la suite de cet
exercice démocratique la désignation
d'un nouveau président pour pour ce
parti donc vous réjouir ou vous déclarez
navré vous choisissez la seconde option
on pense que on ne peut pas se réjouir
mais c'est quand même rappeler à
monsieur copé qu'il n'était pas le
dernier à critiquer le processus des
primaires qui avaient engagé le parti
socialiste et nous l'avons réussi ce
processus et nous avons c'est à partir
de là qu'il ya une dynamique qui
apportait françois hollande aux portes
de la présidentielle et qui a permis
qu'il soit élu donc j'attends plus ump
soit capable de faire l'exercice
démocratique
saremi compression comparé l'élection
mouvementée du nouveau président de
l'ump à la désignation à la soviétique
du nouveau patron du ps il n'y a pas
photo quand même mais ça pose le
problème qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut
faire un congrès
après des élections présidentielles il
faut que le parti socialiste se prennent
ils se présidentialise je n'ai pas peur
de le dire qu'ils prennent la mesure de
ce que c'est que d'accéder à la
présidence de la république il n'y est
pas encore
et l'exercice quand même réussi de
toulouse était quand même meilleur que
celui de reims
est-ce que la victoire de jean françois
copé est une bonne nouvelle pour
françois hollande qui a affirmé son cap
social démocrate
si on se place dans une perspective par
exemple de rapprochement avec le centre
évidemment oui vous faites allusion à
quoi je fais par exemple allusion aux
déclarations ici même il ya une semaine
de françois bayrou qui le premier s'est
réjoui de la tonalité de la conférence
de presse du chef de l'état mais dans la
difficulté ou la france est avec
notamment tous les problèmes que nous
avons à surmonter pour redresser la
france son économie dans la justice on
n'a jamais trop de soutien
on n'a jamais trop d'appuis si françois
bérubé roux la porte et bien tant mieux
mais je souhaite que beaucoup d'autres
appuie les initiatives que prend le
premier ministre jean-marc ayrault avec
les présidents demain je vous seriez
favorable donc un ralliement en bonne et
due forme de françois bayrou qui a
considéré que plus que jamais son vote
en faveur de françois hollande était une
solution quand se détermine par rapport
à un enjeu et par rapport à un programme
et on dit si on est d'accord ou pas ce
n'est pas à moi de dire si on vous dit
on peut y aller il a dit t'as pas un
coup à droite un coup à gauche françois
01 j'ai remarqué est bon c'est un homme
libre
il a dit que le pacte de compétitivité
pour la croissance et l'emploi qu'a
présenté le gouvernement était une bonne
une bonne décision
et qu elle était courageuse exactement
ce que c'est donc mais ces propos ne
vous font pas peur comme l aile gauche
du parti socialiste qui s'inquiètent en
disant oh là là peut-être que demain ils
voient de nouvelles alliances avec le
centre oui mais écoutez on est dans le
vrai sujet en ce moment tous les efforts
du gouvernement sont tendus vers cet
objectif qui passe par le redressement
économique pas pour redresser l'économie
mais parce que si on veut avoir un
modèle social à la hauteur des besoins
des français il faut être capable
d'engager ses réformes dont les membres
et donc il faut rassembler autour d'un
objectif qui est pas celui du parti
socialiste qui est celui de la france
et il se trouve que l'exercice du
pouvoir nos amis en responsabilité il
faut l'assumer pleinement et net et les
soutiens sur la une politique bien sûr
l'info est même parvenu en a besoin et
même parler d'unité nationale comme le
fait françois bayrou
moi ça ne me gêne pas de parler d'unité
nationale vous savez tous les jours je
vois des entreprises j'en ai vu encore
dans mon département aujourd'hui hier
j'étais avec elle à strasbourg et je
vois que les chefs d'entreprise et leurs
salariés sont mobilisés dans un objectif
donc je prends ça pour les sages
d'optimisme il faut que la france
profite de ses atouts de sa mobilisation
c'est vrai que c'est un effort national
accord dont vous parlez aux éclairs
nicole bricq vous approuvez le cap
social démocrate ce que vous iriez
jusqu'à j'en suis une bien sûr alors
est-ce que vous iriez jusqu'à applaudir
un virage social libéral de françois
hollande
je sais pas ce que sa politique de
l'offre des entreprises d'abord la
production avant de redistribuer
françois hollande ne prend personne par
surprise
je me souviens de l'engagement qu'il a
pris 25 janvier quand il a présenté au
grand public ses propositions et ils
étaient déterminés à relever ce pays et
son économie et il était
déjà et depuis longtemps social
démocrate dont il n'y a pas de virage de
l'engagement de françois hollande tout
doit être mobilisé la situation est
grave
je crois que mon petit portefeuille qui
est essentiel puisque c'est un marqueur
de nos déficiences on vole donc le
tocsin et sonné avec les 73 milliards de
déficit du commerce extérieur et c'est
la mobilisation générale sur dites moi
alors mais alors du coup on laisse de
côté bon déjà à les communistes ils ne
sont pas monté dans le wagon du
gouvernement mais les écologistes qui
estiment qu'il ya un après rapport
gallois et qui sont là en participant
sans soutenir vraiment il faudra les
abandonner un jour alors les écologistes
en deux ministres au gouvernement
madame duflot et monsieur canfin et qui
ont l'air parfaitement épanoui dans
l'exercice du pouvoir
mais mme duflot met en oeuvre la
politique du logement qui a été préparé
du reste par le sénat rappelez-vous la
proposition de loi avait été votée au
sénat
donc elle a été élaboré ici donc elle a
l'air parfaitement à son aise et
monsieur qu'enfin avec qui je travaille
beaucoup puisque il s'occupe de la
coopération de l'aide aux pays en
développement
je le croise très souvent il est très
souvent dans des pays où je vais aussi à
l'air parfaitement à son aise
donc il n'ya pas de problème écologistes
on s'aperçoit quand même qu'il y a
peut-être un recentrage jeu poursuit sur
cette idée à nicole bricq de françois
hollande qui a reconnu la liberté de
conscience des mères qui pourront s'ils
le désirent pour un problème de
conscience ne pas procéder à des unions
de personnes du même sexe ça apparaît
quand même comme un recul par rapport à
sa proposition de mariage gay non
la loi sera votée le conseil des
ministres à l'approuver elle sera votée
c'est un angle humeur pourront le faire
mais les primaires ils ne font pas tous
les mariages pour l'épreuve de
conscience
yaz il délègue à une ses adjoints mais
pas pour un problème de conscience mais
je m'emploie du temps je ne sais quoi
mais franchement nicole bricq non ouais
déconner mais lorsqu'on le temps
conscience ne pas union des personnes
alors je ne sais pas si c'est un
problème de conscience ou du chef de
l'état mais je peux comprendre que tout
ce qui touche à la famille renvoie à un
imaginaire que chaque individu peut se
faire de cette famille donc je comprends
que ce soit des réformes de société qui
pose des problèmes à certaines personnes
pour le faire à moitié apprend non non
la loi passera elle sera appliquée et je
la prends cette loi comme un accès à
l'égalité de ceux qui l'on demandait
j'ai vécu l'épisode du pacs j'étais
député octobre 98
oui mais attendez non non non tu en dis
ma part de l'opposition de droite mais
désormais attendu encore sur le 13 ans
après que ce qu'on constate que ça ne
fait plus problème quand l'ump on nous
avait prévenus pire demain c'est de se
marier que le maire de leur commune
refuse pas sûr que les adjoints suivent
alors donc ce sera une réforme a minima
non à moitié nord qu'elle s'appliquera
elle s'appliquera le maire il fera ce
qui fait d'habitude il choisi en accord
avec ceux qui lui demandent
explicitement de faire ou de ne pas
faire
il fera pareil bon si c'est sa
conscience il le clamera peut-être pas
sous tous les toits mais il a la liberté
de faire ou de ne pas faire comme
aujourd'hui
et moi je dis non mais je veux que la
loi s'applique parce que elle elle
satisfait à un désir profond d'égalité
ça vous embrasse bien qu'on soit pas du
tout pas du tout moi c'est moi je
voudrais pour moi je réponds pas pour
les autres m'embarrasse pas du tout je
vous dis on a fait le pacs on en verrait
très loin mais nouveauté vous le
rappeler mais les maires en conscience
pour ne pas la mettre en oeuvre
personnelle mais est ce qu'ils veulent
se marier se marieront la loi
s'appliquera aux mais le maire
ainsi pourront pas dans leur mairie
c'est certainement le cas qui se produit
on va revenir à moody's d'un mot encore
ce qu'on s'aperçoit quand même que
l'argument de l'héritage sarkozy qui
était mis en avant dans un premier temps
par pierre moscovici ne tient pas nicole
bricq si ensuite tous les arguments qui
sont mis en avant par l' agence de
notation vous revendiquez vous votre
ancrage social démocrate peut-être même
social-libéral la chose d'étonnant
social-libéral j'ai dit aussi et voilà
vous le confirmer c'est là donc on est
la juge a expliqué très bien la maison
grasset comme moyen le social comme l'
agence moody's considère que le pacte de
compétitivité ne va pas permettre à la
france donc d'aller vers plus de
croissance plus de compétitivité
écoutez c'est bien non mais j'ai lu
toute la notation oui j'ai pris
connaissance parce que vous savez c'est
toujours nuancé notation et il ne faut
pas prendre un argument le sortir de son
camp 12e arguments d'expliquer pourquoi
l'humain absolument mais la vie est très
nuancée reconnaît que le pacte de
compétitivité est un premier pas mais il
appelle à des réformes encore structurée
sur le marché du travail ou non pas oui
mais il ya une négociation quelle
conduite sous la houlette de mon
collègue michel sapin et je sais
qu'elles se déroulent mieux qu'on aurait
pensé les partenaires sociaux sont
conscients de l'enjeu
ça consiste à sécuriser les parcours au
travail et en même temps à donner plus
de souplesse aux entreprises qu'elle
peut arriver à bon terme avec les jurés
lourd
sinon il y aura une loi donc on a
commencé ça fait un peu plus de six mois
qu'on est là et une notation
c'est toujours une photographie à un
moment donné donc l'argument qui
consiste à dire que c'est
l'état de la france aujourd'hui il est
juste du reste quand la moody's dit dans
sa notation
pour ce qui concerne mon portefeuille
que les échanges commerciaux qui sont
essentiellement européens de la france
avec ses partenaires et comme l'europe
ne va pas très bien pour jean on a des
difficultés se seraient percutés contre
a plus à voir maintenant d'en casser un
jugement exact
bon très bien vous avez cité michel
sapin vous êtes un peu la ministre des
mauvaises nouvelles comme lui puisque
mois après mois vous annoncer les
chiffres du commerce extérieur qui
plongent donc on va en parler avec jean
louis prévost vous allez répondre dans
un instant aux questions de notre
confrère de l'agencé france presse
d'abord eh bien on fait le point sur ce
qui explique ces très mauvais chiffres
où l'on retrouve bien sûr la perte de
compétitivité
le recul du nombre d'entreprises qui
exportent dans notre pays entre autres
facteurs celle enquête signée de
françois goulard c'est devenu un gouffre
ce déficit commercial français plus de
67 milliards d'euros cette année et cela
fait dix ans que ça dure il s'agit de la
différence entre importations et
exportations et ce qu'il révèle c'est
que les entreprises françaises ont bien
du mal à écouler leurs produits à
l'étranger
pour yannick mode et la raison est
simple la concurrence des chinois est la
cause de tous les maux cette artisane de
la porcelaine a vu son business
grignoter d'année en année par les
breloques venant de l' empire du milieu
et qui menacent désormais un patrimoine
national je pense que c'est un danger il
faut quand même protéger notre savoir
faire
on continue à former dans des écoles
d'art des jeunes des apprentis
ce sera pourquoi s'il n'ya plus
d'artisans pour les recevoir et
retransmettre leurs savoirs taxer
fortement les importations de porcelaine
chinoise comme vient de le faire la
commission européenne est une excellente
initiative
selon cette chef d'entreprise qui
regrette cependant qu'elle ne soit que
provisoire
dans cet autre pme on prépare les colis
à livrer qui va partir aujourd'hui c'est
pour la martinique nouvelles icade et
annie nouméa brésil ces matériaux de
construction alain vézère les vents aux
quatre coins du monde depuis 20 ans et
pour ce vieux briscard de l'export le
vrai problème c'est la paperasse les
lourdeurs administratives qui rebute les
patrons français
c'est carrément parcours du combattant
un même remplir un dossier pour la
coface donc des avances sur recettes et
puis qui en plus couvre vos dettes au
cas où on n'arrive rien pas à réussir
c'est d'aider semaine de travail
ça devrait être plus simple puis
simplifiée quand vous faites le premier
dossier pourquoi pas mais là on a
l'impression de à chaque fois qu'on
change de pays de re rappeler à chaque
fois la même chose
handicapé par les coûts les risques
d'impayés un euro fort une concurrence
parfois subventionnés par les états
comme la chine
les entrepreneurs français sont de plus
en plus frileux à se lancer dans la
bataille de l'exportation
seuls 9% des entreprises de l'hexagone
ont relevé le défi cette année
voilà jean luc prévost de l' agence
france-presse est avec nous avons soir
jean-louis nicole bricq
la semaine dernière nous a prévenu que
le chômage allait continuer à augmenter
pendant une année
en ce qui concerne le commerce extérieur
est ce que vous allez nous dire ce soir
peut-être qu'il va continuer de se
creuser
je me suis moi par mois comme vous savez
et j'ai vu les derniers chiffres et sur
les preuves les huit premiers mois de
l'année le déficit est moindre qu'à la
même époque l'année dernière
mais mais j'ai un objectif celui qui m'a
fixé le premier ministre qui est qu'à la
fin du quinquennat nous retrouvions l'
équilibre de notre commerce extérieur
hors énergie parce que la facture
énergétique est extrêmement lourde
donc ça fait que l'objectif que j'ai
c'est de gagner entre 25 et 27 milliards
d'euros à l'exportation et à partir de
là j'ai défini une stratégie et je
présenterai très bientôt mes priorités
d'action concernant le couplage de
l'offre commerciale française qui est
d'excellence dans beaucoup de domaines
avec les priorités pays y est ce que
vous pouvez déjà nous ont parlé un peu
parce que l'allemagne par exemple n'a
pas de ministère du commerce extérieur
pourtant sa balance commerciale est
largement excédentaire
ces entreprises sont largement
compétitive et dynamique à à à
l'exportation comment vous allez faire
en france tout seul un peu pour
redresser cette situation pas tout seul
parce que il ya des réformes
structurelles à faire pour rendre notre
économie plus compétitive
je compte sur tous mes collègues et
notamment les collègues du pôle
économique à bercy je sais que arnaud
montebourg est particulièrement
mobilisée je travaille avec lui pour la
structuration des filières mais je
voudrais dire que pour rapport à
l'allemagne
la ministre du commerce extérieur j'ai
remarqué c'était madame merkel madame
merkel était hier en russie
elle était avant-hier en chine elle
signe les contrats et quand elle se
déplace et bien effectivement là tout
son tissu industriel derrière elle donc
le fait qu'ils aient pas le ministre du
commerce extérieur
n'empêche pas que ce soit un souci
constant des autorités allemandes de la
même manière que j'ai noté qu'il n'avait
pas de dispositif de crédit impôt
recherche
mais qu'ils disent pas qu'ils déposaient
plus de brevets que nous ils ont une
industrie forte qui s'est trouvé bien
placé au moment où les pays émergents
comme la chine ont eu besoin dans leur
marche à l'industrialisation forcé et
rapide de biens d'équipement ils étaient
montés en gamme
ils ont pu vendre leurs produits mais je
pense que la nouvelle étape notamment
dans ces marchés émergents va plutôt se
tourner vers une offre française de
qualité grâce à cette préoccupation
n'est pas sain de régner dans l'esprit
de vos collègues du gouvernement de de
réussir à promouvoir toutes nos
exportations à l'étranger et chaque fois
qu'ils ont un déplacement pourrait
imaginer qu'un ministre se fait sans
même temps le vrp de nous installer
écoutez moi je le fais chaque fois je me
déplace et j'emmène avec moi des petites
et moyennes entreprises
parce que je sais que pour elle c'est
plus difficile
alors il faut réorganiser la chaîne de
l'export ça commence déjà par le
territoire national je lui ai dit mes
pilotes sont les régions avec les
chambres de commerce elles s'organisent
pour sélectionner repérer les
entreprises les porter jusqu'à la porte
de l'exportation ou là elles pourront
aussi être aidé par la banque publique
d'investissement qui va avoir un volet
international avec des crédits
démocratiser accessible aux pme et en
même temps du capital parce qu'une
entreprise qui exporte à la besoin de
fonds propres
si vous avez des exemples concrets parce
que sur les pays émergents qui sont en
pleine expansion jusqu'à la preuve
jusqu'à présent on a l'impression que la
france est un peu frileuse que nous
entreprises serait-elle un peu qu'elles
préfèrent exporter chez nos propres
projets voisins européens
mais il faut être en europe il faut être
en europe parce que nous y vendons des
produits à forte valeur ajoutée la
bataille est rude mais évidemment il
faut comme l'a dit moody's torres
peut-être diversifier notre offre et
être présent dans les pays émergents les
identifier 47 pays
il faut choisir des priorités d'action
qui correspond au grand savoir faire
français
je les résume en quatre grands pôles
tout ce qui concerne la ville durable
nous avons une offre vraiment que ce
soit en termes de transport de proximité
en termes d'efficacité énergétique en
termes d'eau de déchets vraiment
en clair tout ce qui concerne des
besoins nouveaux notamment porté par les
pays en croissance où émergent des
couches moyennes qui veulent mieux se
nourrir mieux s'alimenter
c'est tout ce qui tourne autour de
l'agroalimentaire tout ce qui tourne
aussi autour de la santé du matériel
médical de la cosmétique de la pharmacie
de la parapharmacie
il va y avoir l'accession de ces couches
moyennes tous ses biens et tout ce qui
touche un secteur ô combien important ma
collègue pèlerins le sait très bien
le numérique et tout ce qui va avec leur
coeur donc c'est en fait 4 et pour
l'europe on a reproché à psa ou renault
d'exporter surtout en grèce au portugal
en espagne dans des pays qui ont donc
été touché par la crise est ce que vous
croyez que ce reproche est justifié
écoutez c'était en russie n'y a pas dix
jours j'ai vu que les ventes de peugeot
ont explosé donc je vais
j'ai été au maroc j'ai vu que renaud il
y avait installé une usine parce que je
suis favorable à la colocalisation il
faut être prêt de son marché il faut en
même temps fournir une gamme de services
tout autour
donc je vois que l'internationalisation
des entreprises dès qu'ils sont le
constructeur automobile peut marcher
pour autant qu'on cible bien les pays
qu'on est des bonnes alliances et en
même temps je sais que nous avons dans
le secteur automobile des équipementiers
très performant qui sont bien organisés
et qui conquiert des marchés avec les
constructeurs français mais aussi par la
qualité des produits et des services qui
ne laissait pas abattre par les mauvais
chiffres que vous annoncez donc mois
d'après moi c'est pour vous donner du
coeur à l'ouvragé
non parce que voyez je comprends tout à
fait votre impatience mais toutes les
réformes de structure que nous avons
engagé et il y en a dans le pacte de
compétitivité qu'à présenter jean marc
ayrault notamment toute la réforme des
financements à l'export nos financements
ne sont pas assez compétitifs et la loi
de finances rectificative qui sera voté
avant la fin de l'année commence à les
réformer les allemands un dispositif qui
est celui de financeurs direct qui leur
permet d'avoir des crédits moins cher et
bien il faut qu'on ait la possibilité de
le faire pour des contrats qui
pourraient nous échapper donc ça on le
fait et en même temps il faut qu'on soit
très attractif la france et je note que
nous sommes quand même le premier pays
d'accueil des investissements étrangers
en lieux de production industrielle j'ai
visité la semaine dernière une
entreprise tout près d'ici saurine
italienne qui fait du matériel médical
très haut de gamme j'étais à bordeaux
jeu
jeudi vendredi j'ai vu une de l'énergie
en compétitivité que vous évoquez nicole
bricq 1 donc les 20 milliards d'euros de
crédits d'impôts qui sont offertes aux
entreprises l'institut rexecode à
regarder les choses de près a fait ses
calculs sur les 20 milliards il y en a
que quatre milliards pour l'industrie
qu'est le secteur que vous évoquez là et
il lui est exposée plus que les services
aux grands vents de la mondialisation il
ya un problème là il y aura des dix un
dispositif fiscal qui sera introduit
dans une loi de finances
à ce moment là on aura une étude
d'impact et on verra c'est pas parce que
rex écoles en petit fils alors si vous
me donnez une minute d'une attende parce
que je crois que aujourd'hui segmenté
l'industrie sans regarder les services
ça n'a pas de sens parce que les
services aux industries font partie
d'une chaîne de valeur ajoutée et se
retrouve à l'export et c'est ça qu'il
faut regarder c'est que non en béton par
la qualité d'un certain produits et la
qualité d'un produit
elle est dans le produit lui-même mais
aussi dans son design dans son marketing
et ça c'est du service aux entreprises
et se trouve que cette segmentation n'a
pas beaucoup de valeur comme à l'export
le coup et leur coup ça n'a pas beaucoup
de valeur pourquoi on vous achète un
produit parce que vous avez la qualité
et le prix en face madame ricochet dans
les poches un objet que j'aimerais bien
vous montrer comme des millions de
français voilà c'est s'est imbriqué
voilà vous vous en doutiez ce briquet
et fabriqué en france au palais à dire
le nom est fabriqué en france à redon
mais il est quand même intéressant parce
que c'est peut-être un objet en voie de
disparition
tout simplement parce que le patron de
big monsieur bic a décidé ou a menacé de
réexaminer ses investissements c'est une
union européenne ne lui pas plus contre
les importations de briquets chinois
alors est ce que les français vont
pouvoir continuer à se servir de briques
et fabriqué en france alors tout à
l'heure il y avait un reportage sur la
perte la porcelaine n'avait vu que la
convention
c'est le même cas que la commission dit
vous avez raison
moi j'appuie complètement la déclaration
du patron de big ce que je veux dire je
crois qu'il s'en aille il va rester bien
sûr mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
la politique commerciale elle est
européenne vis-à-vis des pays tiers à
l'union européenne
et c'est vrai que pendant une quinzaine
d'années elle a quand même été très
naïve cette politique commerciale nous
l'avons dit arnaud montebourg et et moi
même et qui fait qu elle se reprenne
parce que justement il faut qu'on ait de
la réciprocité dans les échanges
on ne peut pas continuer à se battre nos
entreprises ne peuvent pas se battre si
elles n'ont pas les mêmes armes que les
autres
donc chaque fois qu'on pourra faire
constater une pratique anti dumping et
pâtes lentilles de mon pays a oscillé
les aides d'état dont bénéficient des
entreprises de pays tiers mais chaque
fois que le pool la réciprocité ne sera
pas au rendez vous il faut engager des
procédures
il faut que l'europe se fasse respecter
l'europe c'est avec les états unis la
deuxième puissance commerciale du monde
c'est une force de marcher il faut s'en
servir
et moi je vais rencontrer le commissaire
au commerce extérieur pour la deuxième
fois vendredi et nous avons un conseil
des ministres du commerce extérieur le
29 et demain je fais une communication
sur la politique commerciale en conseil
des ministres et je peux vous dit
que la france que quand même la deuxième
économie d'europe elle va faire entendre
sa voix en la matière et que la pratique
libérale il faut le dire des accords de
libre échange c'est terminé et que nous
ne signerons un accord de libre-échange
désormais qu'à partir du moment où on
nous démontrera qu'il y à la réciprocité
est est ce que vous êtes entendu par
l'ensemble de nos partenaires européens
ce n'est pas facile
j'ai fait le tour des capitales
européennes entre deux voyages au long
cours pour trouver des alliés de la
réciprocité
mais par exemple oui c'est dur non je ne
suis pas sûr parce que j'ai recensé
quand même plusieurs pays qui sont
d'accord avec moi donc pas des moindres
l'italien mario monti l'espagne la
pologne où j'étais avec le président de
la république la semaine dernière pas
des moindres mais est ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'on a une occasion de
d'avoir une arme dans la poche dans les
négociations avec les pays tiers
c'est de donner droit à la déclaration
du conseil européen de juin réitéré en
octobre à savoir que les états doivent
permettent l'aboutissement du règlement
de la commission qui nous donne un accès
identique à celui que l'europe of sur
les marchés publics
il ya 12 milliards à la clé nos
entreprises aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas
concourir armes égales sur les marchés
publics des pays tiers c'est vrai pour
les etats unis c'est vrai pont japon
c'est vrai pour le canada mais chinois
sont prévenus nicole bricq arrive avec
arnaud montebourg merci jean louis
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir perrine
tarneaud arrive maintenant perrine de
public sénat
juste avant ce rappel d'un emmy the
d'infini pisode marquantes de la
formation du gouvernement et roddick au
le brief est restée bien présente dans
votre mémoire à vous aussi
je parle de votre exfiltration express
du ministère de l'écologie sur la
question du pétrole offshore alexandra
colinot ce 22 juin dans la cour du
ministère de l'écologie l'ambiance est
pesante
après seulement un mois d'exercice
nicole bricq qui passe la main à
delphine batho son débarquement lui a
été annoncée la veille par téléphone
ce jeu de chaises musicales a été
orchestré quelques jours auparavant
pendant le sommet de rio
françois hollande qui l'accompagnent ne
lui a rien dit elle qui a affirmé avoir
des appuis de poids au sein du
gouvernement s'est retrouvé face à un
mur celui du forage pétrolier en guyane
dix jours après sa nomination à
l'écologie nicole bricq refuse de signer
le lancement de ces forages et demande
une remise à plat des permis
d'exploitation
mais les navires sont déjà en route
entre 8 et 10 milliards d'euros
d'investissements de shell et total sont
en jeu 600 emplois attendent l'industrie
pétrolière gagnent la bataille
c'est vrai il y avait les arguments
techniques qui pouvait justifier le
maintien notamment en fait que le
contrat a été signé et qu'il y avait un
débit important pour ça ce sont des
choses qu'on peut entendre
après est ce que pour autant cela
justifierait utilise le conditionnel
une telle décision d'autant plus que
l'année d'avant
nous étions toutes et tous y compris le
premier ministre a dénoncé ces forages
en guyane mais nicole bricq a aussi
commis un impair politique car elle n'a
pas averti matignon de cette décision
l'ancienne sénatrice au caractère réputé
tranchant ne s'est pas pliée aux règles
imposées par sa nouvelle fonction c'est
une personne qui s'efforce d'aller
jusqu'au bout naturellement est là c'est
d'abord un peu ingrat il faut le
reconnaître et ne semble pas faire
d'effort particulier pour pour gommer
c'est d'abord un gr nicole bricq a
finalement accepté le portefeuille du
commerce extérieur se refusant au
moindre commentaire
mais s'assurant qu'elles garderaient le
même rang protocolaire au sein du
gouvernement
les forages en guyane eux ont débuté
comme prévu en juillet quinze jours
après le remaniement ministériel
voilà perrine tarneaud est avec nous il
ya des mots qui vous ont surpris dans ce
reportage
il est ingrat philippe parini de vous
traiter ainsi vous son ancien rapporteur
à la commission des finances qu'il
préside
ouais il connaissons son métier un mais
venaient bien son sujet son geste séjour
moi j'aime bien
marini parce que on débat oui mais voilà
un argument contre abonnement péter
célèbre c'est un bon mais bon il
quelquefois il une nouvelle fois aussi
fait remarquer sur vous votre caractère
ancien puits n'a pas changé mais je ne
me laisse pas faire ça c'est vrai bon
ben je veux pas me changer
1 comme disait le général de gaulle va
être 67 ans et ben moi à 65 pour changer
oui je me laisse pas faire j'ai des
convictions fait des fonds pour revenir
à cette affaire de votre changement de
poste au tout début du gouvernement
ayrault pour revenir sur cette promotion
comme avait dit à l'époque cécile duflot
sympa les femmes entrent sans le
gouvernement on peut dire c'était entre
parenthèses est-ce que vous pensez que
cette exfiltration de l'écologie vers le
commerce extérieur était justement votre
caractère non non non non non écouter il
y avait quand même un gros trou dans le
premier gouvernement ne pas mettre de
ministre du commerce extérieur
ça faisait tâche quand on avait à
l'époque 70 milliards de déficit
aujourd'hui on en a 60 13 sur l'année
2011 pourtant que c'est l'écologie est
bien c'est que je pense que
c'était un bon choix donc choisir moi
moi je vais me disiez pas vraiment c'est
maintenant je n'ai rien dit je n'ai rien
n'y est jamais bon intérieur jamais
parlé de cette affaire parce que j'ai
une philosophie de vie je regarde
toujours devant
j'aime la vie donc j'aime le corps à
corps avec la vie donc je n'ai aucune
tendance à la morbidité
je ne sais pas ce que c'est je ne
connais pas la rancune je suis comme ça
donc gg allin jamais autant vous aidons
nos langues très honnête bio il sait
qu'il va vous débarquez vous dit qu'il
ne vous dit pas un mot
bah il a autre chose à faire il avait a
rencontré le premier ministre turc
c'était autrement plus important que de
s'occuper de madame nicole bricq
mais sur le fond quand même est-ce que
vous avez perdu le ministère de
l'écologie en raison de votre volonté de
remettre à plat ces permis d'exploration
je ne sais pas et ce que je regarde
vous n'avez jamais eu d'explication de
la part du président qui sortit de
françois hollande
je n'en cherche pas c'est tellement à
faire mais je tiens quand même signaler
que quand le premier ministre a fait
début juillet sa déclaration de
politique générale qu'est ce qu'il a dit
qu' il mettait à l'agenda du
gouvernement la réforme du code minier
je me suis swing demba qui mise à plat
des pour la réforme le code laura
réforme du code minier
ça me paraît le plus important et c'est
acquis mais des décisions auront passé
avait été utile oui mais les décisions
de remise à plat ce monde s'est permis
en guyane pour finir cette question ces
décisions ont été prises en accord avec
arnaud montebourg pourquoi vous vous
avez été sanctionner entre guillemets et
pas lui est-ce qu'il abaisse de poids
politique demandé ça d'abord j'ai pas
été je considère pas que c'est avec une
sanction parce que la fonction que
j'occupe elle est passionnante
je suis engagé à bercy ce qui n'est pas
pour me déplaire franchement sachant ce
que je fais je faisais il a choisi les
parlementaires ça ça m'intéresse parce
que ça participe au relèvement de la
france et je pense que tous les efforts
du gouvernement sont tendus vers ce
relèvement de l'économie française c'est
capital alors une question de plus
légère avec notre partenaire orange
leurs applications tivi tchèque une
question de zyed il paraît que vous
testez prendre l'avion est ce que de
l'info de la résidence c'est une légende
une légende je préfère le train ben oui
parce que si on peut se déplacer on voit
là mais je ne vais pas en train à moscou
je ne vais pas en train anaérobie voilà
mais que s'il faut que je suis content
ce qu'une légende
bon ben voilà pour de téléspectateurs
elle dit qu'il se trouve c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour le commerce extérieur
voilà des questions peut-être plus
politique nicole bricq avec notamment la
forte mobilisation ce week-end contre le
futur aéroport de notre dame des landes
à côté de nantes
est-ce que la position qu'ils fassent un
flexible un du gouvernement
comment du gouvernement attendait il ya
eu des tas de procédure ouais enfin bon
je vous en lire un mot quand même de
tout ça comme on trouve justement la
porte de sortie dans ce conflit qui dure
depuis maintenant des années et qui est
en train de s'enliser et prendre un
autre aspect chien
je pense que connaissant bien les
collectivités locales
c'est souvent qu'elles doivent faire des
arbitrages lourds et qu' elles font coût
avantage un projet économique c'est un
projet économique sur la façade
atlantique ouest
c'est un projet économique c'est un
projet de développement elles veulent le
faire
elle pèse le pour et le contre par
rapport à des zones naturelles et il ya
souvent ces arbitrages à faire
alors est-ce qu'il faut sanctuariser
advitam eternam une des zones naturelles
au nom de la nature est ce qu'il faut
faire des choix économiques je pense
qu'après réflexion
après une longue réflexion les élus ont
choisi de donner l'avantagé à l'économie
je les comprends je les comprends ce
sont des arbitrages difficiles qui se
présente là bas et qui peuvent se
présenter y compris en ile de france je
le sais est que à chaque fois
l'arbitrage est difficile le choix a été
fait il est assumé il faut qu'il aille à
son terme même s'il faudra aussi
certainement conserver le premier
aéroport celui qui existe actuellement
puisque airbus a construit une
in juste à côté investi plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros qu'il aura
toujours besoin de cette piste quoi mais
je voulais dit je pense que la réflexion
qui a présidé à la décision des élus a
été sérieuse et elle est assumée par les
édiles vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
nos ministres écologistes avaient l'air
heureux au gouvernement ben ils
manifestent contre une décision adoptée
par google
enfin est-ce qu'on peut quand même avoir
des verts dans les manifestations et des
verts au gouvernement cécile duflot
revendique d'ailleurs elle-même cette
position a dit que c'est une position
historique dans l'histoire politique
française et à l'arrestation n'a pas été
interdite à partir de là comment
voulez-vous ne restait de droit les
comportements de jourgnac héros et
manifester avec des pancartes contre
jean marc ayrault s'est très mal de
manifester contre le premier ministre
que je soutiens à fond
voilà comme premier ministre guillaume
soro guillaume ont posé la question du
maintien et met en place pour des
questions tous les jours il est patron
de groupe écolo au sénat
bon il suit où il précède ses troupes
c'est son affaire mais mme duflot
monsieur le mans ça ils sont un peu
quand même hein bah ça sent très bon
mais peut-être qu'il est rattrapé
quelques fois aussi par ses troupes
elle est une autre affaire celle des gaz
de schiste que vous connaissez bien
aussi amicale brille comme un leurre que
le ton du gouvernement a un petit peu
changé est ce qu'on va pouvoir se passer
des gaz de schiste en france
écoutez il doit y avoir un débat énergie
on va à l'occasion de la du nouveau mix
énergétique la france pareil un
engagement par rapport au nucléaire il
faut regarder ce débat sereinement et
dedans il y a pas de tabou donc le débat
sur le gaz et le pétrole de schiste
il faut la voir lorsque j'observe c'est
toujours pareil
la réforme du code minier m'apparaît
essentiel comme pistes pour sortir par
le haut toute cette affaire parce que il
faut permettre
comme le rapport gossement l'avait fait
de consulter le public de consulter les
élus il faut des procédures
démocratiques et il faut aussi se poser
la question comment on fait pour nos
entreprises notamment ceux qu'on appelle
les électro intensives comment elles
peuvent garder de la compétitivité au
travers des prêts étiez dans
l'opposition - est fort que d'autres
pays concurrents
oui et puis on voit quand même les états
unis qui exploite aujourd'hui et les gaz
de schiste eagle démarche de
compétitivité ils ont une énergie qui
est bien meilleur marché ce que ça c'est
pas un exemple à sion je vais parler
derrière le carré dit ça fait partie du
débat
nous étions en pologne avec le président
de la république
legalis on connaît qui n'ont pas
commencé mais qui explorent des gaz de
schiste ils pensent qu'ils n'ont pas
l'eldorado qu'on leur avait promis
on n'est pas là pour favoriser les cours
de bourse des des opérateurs à new york
on n'est pas là pour ça on est là pour
se poser les bonnes questions et d'y
aller le bon mix énergétique
quels sont les besoins de l'économie
quels sont les avantages qu'on peut
donner à notre à neutre notre industrie
notamment parce que l'énergie ça coûte
cher à certaines industries
il faut qu'on puisse les garder en
france donc ça fait donc encourager on
est donc encourager et continuer la
recherche en france pour trouver des
méthodes d'exploitation t il ya eu une
baisse qui a été rempli par le président
de la république pas de fracture
hydraulique
bon voilà c'est tout ils ont ouvert la
porte aux chercheurs c'est important
vous espérer qu'un jour on puisse dire
le garder si cette opération n'est pas
celle
qui fait des dégâts environnementaux
donc la preuve est dans le camp de ceux
qui veulent le faire à l'époque dans le
camp du gouvernement et du président de
la république vient dernière question je
reviens d'un mot et réussir votre
changement de filtre ministériel dès le
début du gouvernement héros finalement
c'est paradoxal puisque on a beaucoup
reproché le manque d'autorité
jean marc ayrault vous avez vous en avez
été sa première victime de son autorité
moi je vais écouter ce que j'ai une tête
de victimes franchement non
comme disait ma mère donc sarangi pitié
or beaucoup au premier ministre ministre
de plein exercice j'ai un portefeuille
exaltant un objectif très difficile à
atteindre c'est un challenge pour moi et
je le prends personnellement c'est
formidable et vous avez pas forcément la
tête du lit de la victime mais en
politique il faut savoir rester
imperturbable n'est ce pas nicole bricq
restera des circonstances merci du père
et du ministre du commerce extérieur
bonsoir à tous et à très vite